I am fanboy hear me roar so I don't have
any particular impetus to talk about
this particular subject but it was on my
mind today and I thought I'd record some
thoughts and the question occurred to me
how much should creators of
entertainment listen to the fans because
we've entered an era of unprecedented
connection between fans of some piece of
entertainment and the makers of that
entertainment thanks to social media
Twitter Instagram whatever we can reach
out if not directly to them at the very
least we can consolidate in a unified
voice through social media that is loud
enough that they will hear it
even if we can't do a direct one-on-one
communication with them but is it really
a good thing
and what I say creators I don't even
mean exclusively the original creators
because we live in the age of adaptation
so oftentimes I'm also referring to the
people who are adapting an existing
piece of media because they certainly
have their you have their ears on what
the fans are saying as well I don't want
to say you have to listen to what they
want and I'll go into some of the
reasons why maybe you probably shouldn't
but you shouldn't deliberately go out of
your way to tick them off I think really
you want to go way back historic the big
case in point Arthur Conan Doyle was
really really sick of writing Sherlock
so let me kill him until the fan out
where I was so loud and nothing else he
was doing was bringing much of a
paycheck he was just he just went fine
he helped bring them back I mean the
only reason he killed Sherlock wasn't
because like he had been building to it
it wasn't his master plan it was it it
wasn't you know some part of conclusion
of a grand stories like he just was sick
of writing it and so he did indeed just
kill off like bear stop asking me to
write more here's the problem with fans
and but listening to fans ask a fan what
they want and what they'll tell you is
they want more of the stuff they already
love and that is how you get in
basically into in this
you know masturbatory nostalgia where
we're just cycling around the same stuff
over and over and over again because you
ask us what we want and we tell you it's
it's what we already love most fans
aren't gonna think of the new thing that
they don't even know that they will love
once you give it to them
so Wow fan reaction to something that
you have done is probably valuable and
worth you know getting a read on what is
a bad idea is sort of preemptively
trying to get a gauge on what fans will
think before you've actually done
something and also fans we need to
understand our place in all this as well
because when we're talking about
something like a comic book a book
series yes the fans keep it going but
also in a lot of those cases there are
fewer creators involved in it makes it
easier for them to sort of maintain
their level of control like I don't
think george RR martin gives a dang what
any fan thinks about anything that he's
writing for these last two books because
it's his is 100% his and he does not
behold into anybody else
the more people get involved the more
voices are like maybe did not do that
and you know again you can get the
stagnation thing but as things get into
bigger bigger mediums like television
like film especially we need to
understand as fans that we are not
enough on our own to make something
profitable especially in the case of a
movie now that doesn't mean that our
opinions don't matter or shouldn't count
but we need to understand that when you
look at the box office for the latest
superhero blockbuster the percentage of
that box office that is the fans I mean
like the fans who were fans of this
thing before it was even a movie that's
a small percentage of the overall box
office they need the mainstream who
maybe folks who have heard of whatever
the thing is but they're not devoted
fans of it and without
the thing doesn't become a glorified hit
now that doesn't mean fans are
irrelevant because sometimes you know if
fans are loud enough about this is awful
that can filter out to the mainstream
they go oh well the people who like this
thing don't even like this movie I'm not
gonna bother with that so again it can
be a loud and a powerful voice but raw
numbers we don't have as much power as
we think we do and yet especially in the
case of movies and and television but
movies especially studios are terrified
of fans which has led to sort of my big
bug bear with adaptations lately which
is a fear of actually properly adapting
a material because at this point I think
studios are so a desperate to meet fans
approval and so debt and so intensely
terrified about them crapping all over
something and potentially poisoning the
minds of the mainstream audience when
they do so that when especially a book
gets adapted into a film or a TV show
they change almost nothing they at best
they'll remove a few things to get the
runtime down to a reasonable length but
they will change almost nothing and I'm
sure fans will go why isn't that the
best thing ever why would we want it
changed well two reasons first of all
different things work better in
different media you need to be you need
to allow for certain embellishments
especially in the case of film if you've
got a filmmaker of any degree of vision
you need to allow them to put their own
stamp on it otherwise you're just gonna
get completely cookie cutter your
adaptations of stuff I like to use the
Harry Potter movies as a good example on
this so the first two Harry Potter
movies are by far the blandest of the
lot and they're also the most faithful
in terms of what they adapt to the
screen they keep the most stuff they
they add the least in terms of you know
things moments or ideas or character
beats that that didn't originate in the
novels but still make sense starting
with the third one and going forward
that stuff started having more and more
and that in my mind is proper adaptation
just doing a copy/paste job from a novel
to a script and then just filming that
and going out a checklist of all the
scenes the fans are expecting to see
that's not proper adaptation in my book
that's that's just a really expensive
fan film proper adaptation requires
tweaking the material so that it works
better in the medium you're now telling
the story in this is a big part of why I
really have a strong distaste for the
Watchmen movie I know some people like
it but I actually hate for how slavishly
faithful it is because that story was
written so specifically to work on the
comic book page and they didn't make the
adjustments you need to to make it work
better on film and so the film is just
an inferior version of the same story
because it's not being told in the
medium it was designed for now this is
actually part of why I have really
enjoyed a lot of the superhero
adaptations that have happened because
very few of them have been adapting
specific storylines directly they've
been pulling from all sorts of
influences but by and large these films
from whatever studio's making them it's
been true of the DC EU movies has been
drove the MCU these films are taking a
superhero character and even if they're
retelling like the origin which is a
specific story they're just hitting a
couple of beats about it but then
allowing all these things from all these
years to seep into it all these
characters across a hero's entire
timeline you know bringing in villains
that probably weren't even around what
the character truly had their origins
story and all this other stuff and that
is proper adaptation that rather than
trying to go rigidly alright this story
here as a movie they are going okay
here's the character here's the essence
of this character here's the essence of
their villains here's the essence of the
kinds of stories that they're in how
we get something that captures all of
this and that's why something like say
Civil War was so good you know it took
its title from a very specific
storyline from the Marvel Comics and
borrowed a couple of key elements from
it it is a different there's almost no
similarity plot wise in terms of the
Civil War comic book and the Civil War
movie they bear a very superficial
relationship to each other and in my
mind that's perfect
because I can recognize the elements
where they took the story points but
they've done something new with it now
granted all of that is easier when you
are doing comic book you know superhero
stories specifically that with comic
books that have been ongoing for a very
long time and aren't defined by this is
the definitive story it gets harder when
you're adapting a specific story which
if you're doing something other than
superheroes that's largely what you're
doing you're adapting a specific story
but do you want to know what kind of
movies you get when you allow a
filmmaker to take the core ideas and the
core characters from a source work but
do their own thing completely with it
you get your asset park you get jaws if
you I mean odds are you've probably seen
either or both of those movies and I
didn't mean to pick two Steven Spielberg
movies there's they both happen to be
really good examples of this but in both
cases the books very different and in my
personal opinion the books are not as
good the jaws book is yes kind of a mess
honestly there's a lot of weird and ugly
and messy subplots that the movie just
gets rid of and as far as Jurassic Park
goes the the book the book is a lot more
technically minded and as a result it
kind of loses the threat of just the fun
of look at these dinosaurs running
around cuz it gets kind of hung up on
the science we just don't like Michael
Crichton tended to do now some people do
prefer that but I think whether you
prefer the book or the movie of Jurassic
Park you do get the wonderful experience
that each is a different experience
to have and both are valid and both are
recognizable as being connected to each
other but you don't see the movie and go
well I don't need to read the book now
no you can't sir read the book and get a
completely different experience and yet
still recognize that it is the same
thing but when you remain slavish to the
source material which is what happens
when creators and studios are so scared
of fans as they are right now we just
get boring things I mean especially for
fans and that's something I will never
understand where fans get overly upset
about how much things got changed from
the original works like but you you've
read the book I mean do you really want
something that is nothing but the thing
you already know I mean I get the
nostalgic value in that but aren't you
gonna be bored and look having said that
that not every divergence that ever
happens with an adaptation when they do
go their own direction with it actually
works The Hobbit trilogy which I can't
stand took a lot of you know it went its
own way with it I won't take that away
from it but boy didn't work but under
the but the reason it didn't work is
because it lost the heart of the
material the reason the Hobbit films are
a really poor adaptation of a hobbit
aren't because of the plot points that
got changed is because they changed the
purpose of it because the purpose of the
Hobbit the book is to follow Bilbo on a
fun adventure that he goes on the
purpose of The Hobbit movies is to build
up to Lord of the Rings they're serving
completely different functions and at
their heart they don't have the same
mission they don't have the same intent
and that is what leads to all the other
junk about those movies that doesn't
work but at the same time I have to
recognize that if they had done movies
that were nothing except exactly what
was in the book I would have been bored
I mean it's a big part of why the Lord
of the Rings movies worked is because I
mean the Lord of the Rings books they're
dry Affairs they read almost like
history texts so to
give it that more adventurous feel the
more adventurous vibe to ditch a lot of
the history and the men the political
minutia and the goings-on of that sort
of stuff in people's lineage and all
that to toss that aside and focus on the
action in the combat which is not as
prevalent in the novels that is proper
adaptation because that is the sort of
stuff that film does well so that is
where it was correct by keeping the
heart of the story still intact and it
is the journey to take care of the ring
it is the the bonding and the end the
stress put on the bonds between these
characters and keeping an eye on that
but putting more of a focus on the
action than was in the books because
again the action is a more visceral
thing film does visceral better than it
does the more intellectual expositional
stuff which is all over the novels and
yet I still know fans of the book who
get really upset about specific minutiae
details that didn't make the movie I get
when something that you loved doesn't
make the cut it's disappointing I've had
that happen with stuff that I knew the
source material really well before
seeing the adaptation but I will swallow
that go like would that thing that I
wish was there truly have made this
adaptation a superior piece of work and
nine times out of ten the answer is no
not really it just would have made me
happy so as I said I really think that
creators need to be aware of fan
reaction and fan desires to a certain
extent but also not feel that they are
beholden to them because I think you can
see in the way that certain television
shows evolve especially over time that
oftentimes the longer a TV show goes on
and the more the fans keep calling for
something to happen eventually it does
and then the show's not as good I mean
the classic example is just any show
that had a will they won't they you know
sort of relationship between a male and
female character once they do the show
isn't the same after that and it's
usually some
the fans have been calling for like just
get them together and then you do and
it's like well what's the point now like
you should never you should never do
that unless you're about to end the show
you you should always be dangling those
sorts of things I mean it's the reason
I'm Doctor Who I I'm putting my foot
down
I never want to see a ginger doctor I
want the doctor wishing to be ginger
every single regeneration if they ever
make the doctor ginger that should be
the last regeneration the doctor ever
gets because after that what more if you
have to tease us with I'm being slightly
facetious I that kind of exaggerating a
very minor point but it's still it's it
speaks to my overall personal sentiment
so I think I've rambled on and gone
tangent enough for this particular video
so what are your thoughts on any of this
whatever they are drop something down in
the comments let's talk about it don't
forget to like subscribe check me out on
Twitter right council of geeks give a
listen at the council of geeks podcast
available on iTunes and stitcher I'm
also one half of the punch like a girl
podcast also available on iTunes and
stitcher so until next time this council
is adjourned
[Applause]
[Applause]